a couple years ago I asked my dad I was
like Dad did you ever you ever love
anybody outside of Mom oh yeah I was
like what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what a
winning answer that it's a grown-up
conversation that is your dad I just
wanted to ask him your dad's a sex
opportunity he said yeah you stayed at
her house and I was like whoa what yeah
Mom did too we were there that one time
I was like we what 2002 my whole family
went to Vietnam stayed at this like one
family's house so I do remember meeting
this lady she was like kids and stuff
they all look like you exactly welcome
Anthony I was like dang you took Mom to
like your ex-girlfriend's house and I
was like what happened and he just says
nonchalantly because he doesn't know how
to [ __ ] add emotional tone to
anything he's like oh well you know uh
during the war me and her were together
there was just a time where we had to
leave and then so I had to get into a
boat with my family and I was like come
on let's go she's like no I can't I
can't leave my family that was it whoa
damn those would be like right anime
stories like well I was going in her
[ __ ] and then she [ __ ] all over my
[ __ ]